I invested money on a halal company's
shares 3 months earlier but recently I
checked that the company has become
haram because interestbearing debt to
total assets has exceeded to
43.75%. Due to which the stock has
become haram but previously the stock
was halal what should I do?
The question posed by brother sadic that
he invest in halal shares and maybe he
has knowledge about how to invest in
stocks which are shar compliant and when
he bought these shares 3 months earlier
these shares were halal but now when he
checked up he came to know that the
interest bearing ratio or the debt ratio
has increased to more than 43% 43.75%.
So now you think what should you do
first if you have heard answers on how
do you come to know whether the stocks
you're purchasing of particular company
shall be compliant or not and there are
five categories the first is that the
core activity should be halal and then
you should see to it that they're not
involved in any interest bearing
activity as a company which is giving
loan on interest etc then the cash and
the debt ratio should be less and any
haram activity should be less than 5%.
These were discussed in detail. So the
president has checked and he realized
after 3 months that the debt ratio has
increased to more than 43% and that
makes the share. What should he do? He
should immediately sell the share. Sell
the share and invest in a halal share.
But while investing see to it that there
are two types of sharia compliant. One
is that the company itself has a Sharia
board and it is Sharia compliant by
nature. By nature means it has a board.
So investing in Sharia compliant shares
which have a Sharia board is the best.
And Malaysia where I live there are many
Sharia compliant shares and it is there
in the stock itself it mentions Sharia
compliant halal okay not Sharia
compliant. In India there are very few
which are basically which have Sharia
board etc. hardly any but even if it
doesn't have a Sharia board it can be
Sharia compliant by nature because it
may not be a debt company it may not be
taking loans the core activity may not
be haram it may be dealing with maybe
pharmaceuticals so by nature it can be
so some companies by nature if they
don't have a sharia board so it can
remain halal but some companies can keep
on changing like the one you said invest
in a company and that company has got
involved into debt you know So in this
you have to keep on monitoring but the
best is to invest in companies which are
Sharia board. The second best would be
by nature is Sharia compliant. You know
that the company will not involved in
taking loans from the bank and by nature
it is such a company. It is a strong
company. It's a big company and it's
involved in products which are halal.
And then the third would be the company
which may keep on changing. So it is
preferable to avoid investing in
companies which can change because you
have to keep on monitoring and then if
it's haram you have to sell it. So why
let yourself involve in investing even
for a small period whether it be a month
or whether it be a week. So best is to
involve in companies which have a Sharia
board as I mentioned second best is by
nature if it's Sharia compliant but now
the solution for that see to it sell it
immediately if you want to continue
investing in Sharia compliance share see
to it that you invest in a company which
has the Sharia board or it is Sharia
compliant hope that answers the